This message is brought to you by Deadpool
It started as an idea
What if we made a Deadpool movie?
There was only a few of us back then, and looking back
we had no idea how big it would become.
So innocent.
And yet the momentum that had started,
it was not really what we had in mind,
though.
That didn't help things.
It was more of a hell no. To be honest.
I mean, we eventually stopped asking.
But I promise you, I'm looking into it.
But once the movie got greenlit,
I went on a massive coke bender.
So this little hazy for me.
They tell me the movie did well, though
ten years into it,
phase one has exceeded our wildest expectations.
Zero.
If you told me back then that one movie would spawn
an expansive two movie universe,
I have said that you were crazy.
But here we are with actual actors.
A moderate special effects budget
and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase two.
Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort
There's a brand new Deadpool
3 teaser with more footage of Deadpool
and Wolverine with more Easter eggs and references
to what's going on in the movie, how this all fits
into the rest of the MCU
and the upcoming Avengers movies like Secret Wars.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel,
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
They're going to be dropping the full Deadpool
three trailer at the Super Bowl in a couple of weeks.
Of course, I'll do videos for it,
So be sure to subscribe to the channel,
to be the first to watch that They also just started
filming Daredevil Born Again
and they brought back pretty much everybody
that made the Marvel Netflix series.
so like right now is probably one of the best times
to be a huge Marvel fan because they're making
some of the best stuff that they're going
to be releasing in the next couple of years.
Deadpool three is just like the next big thing
because it's the next big movie
they're releasing in the next six months or so.
but the new footage looks like Deadpool and Wolverine
when they're stuck on this same world where they wind
up meeting the other Deadpool variants like Dog Pool,
the samurai looking version of Deadpool.
right now, it seems like they might be
on the Void planet from Loki.
And they're just going to say that it's the MCU
version of Battle World from the Secret Wars comics,
because there are TBA agents in full riot
gear walking around behind them.
In some of these scenes,
I don't know if this is going to be Samurai Deadpool
from the comics
because he is an actual Marvel comic book character.
But fans are calling him that because of his long hair.
The man bun, the superior armor.
They're just going to be a lot of different
Deadpool variants in the movie.
we already got a bunch of footage about them.
So I did a whole separate video explaining
what's going on with those characters.
I'll link that below in the description.
but it looks like in this scene,
the two of them have already battled it out
and Wolverine has at least briefly relented
and agreed to help Deadpool.
And they're just heading to or leaving the rendezvous
with the Deadpool core
because Deadpool seems way, way too happy in this
Like this scene is meant to pay off the Deadpool
two post-credits scene where he said that he was going
to show up some day and ask him to help him out.
and Wolverine can't stand
him, Keeps knocking him down, pushing away,
especially after he starts to ride piggyback
the weird thing, though, is the actual environment
that they're in in this scene,
like the grass and the planet seems way
nicer than the ground in the void planet.
The sky is all nice.
It's not overcast, I think you have to remember the way
they actually treated the scenes here.
Like when they were filming this scene
for the Loki series, when they were on the Void Planet,
they just tuned it in post-production to make it
look really overcast, that really crazy looking sky.
it just wound up affecting the coloration
of everything on the planet, making it look ancient
because it was meant to look ancient because everything
is stuck there from across all of time.
Any time the TVA pruned something from anywhere
in the timeline from millions of years ago
to present day,
it just immediately winds up on the void planet.
even though a lot of the people that get stuck on
that planet are variants
of really powerful Marvel characters
who have really, really long lifespans.
part of the ideas that he remains
was using the alliance creature
as a sort of galactic trash compactor
because it was capable of consuming entire timelines,
not just regular matter,
but entire timelines, entire universes.
so they prune stuff, send it to the void,
and just wait for a life to consume it.
kind of like a galactic garbage dump.
So when the actual Deadpool three movie, this scene
probably isn't going to be a bright sunny day
Notice Wolverine still has his full sleeves
on the suit, but Hugh Jackman literally just posts
a picture publicly to celebrate them
finishing filming last week,
showing Wolverine without any sleeves.
back in the day. People would have called this a leak.
But because social media that the actors pose
is scrutinized so much that there's
so much planning that goes into stuff like this,
even though a lot of Ryan Reynolds
jokey posts seem like they're not planned,
they are heavily planned.
so usually when stuff like this leaks out, it's
because the studio wants it
to leak out to drive hype for the movie
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman.
The Deadpool movie just in general are just way better
at doing that than a lot of other movies.
Not just Marvel movies, but all movies.
so it actually seems now like at some point
during the end of the movie or like the final battle,
the sleeves get ripped off his suit
and he becomes way more comic book accurate.
They also separately released some promo pictures
with a look at his helmet
in the movie, answering a ton of questions
about the rest of his suit.
Most of the footage and promo pictures
we've seen so far have been Wolverine
without the helmet and with sleeves.
like a lot of the X-Men are going to be cameos
from the classic Marvel X-Men movies.
And Fantastic Four movies
will look more like the versions
you saw on X-Men Animated Series in the classic stuff.
So everyone just assumed that at some point
Wolverine might lose the sleeves and get the helmet.
this just answers a lot of those questions.
even the Wolverine suit
does look closer to the design from X-Men,
the animated series is actually meant
to be based on the astonishing X-Men
version of his suit, which funny enough was from Joss
Whedon's run the X-Men comics.
Like he created that run we before he was disgraced.
More recently,
a lot of people were hoping we'd see something close
to that version of the X-Men in the movies.
It's a great story.
If you haven't read it,
even though it is kind of awkward now with everything
that happened to Joss Whedon in real life,
there were even a few things that Marvel
has already borrowed from that particular X-Men
run in the movies like Nick Fury, Saber Space Station
during Spider-Man, far from Home in the Marvel's movie.
That debuted in the Astonishing X-Men.
It was called the Swords Space Station.
Then it was run by Abigail Brand,
who was an X-Men based character with Mutant Powers.
They even wound up using it in
a lot of the animated TV series a while ago to
that was why a lot of people thought
that Amelia Clarke would take on an Abigail
Brand kind of role in the MCU
after Secret Invasion in the Marvel's movie,
because it was so much Skrull
related stuff happening with that space station.
but it actually turns out that Marvel
has totally different plans for the character,
like they're planning on using her in an Excalibur
like team with Kit Harington's, Black Knight,
and they'll be kind of like a British version
of The Avengers based on Excalibur from the comics,
which the connection here,
because we're talking about Deadpool,
is also kind of an X-Men team.
Excalibur is actually based on
storyline is from X-Men comics
like the original Excalibur team
formed during a Professor X storyline.
Nightcrawler was a big part of the team.
Other big X-Men characters were featured on the team.
Deadpool three is meant to be the beginning of them
doing a lot of the core X-Men team stuff in the movies.
Eventually we'll see more of that
starting in the main 616 MCU universe.
Double three is kind of an exception
in that it's an MCU movie because the TVA is involved,
like there's TVA characters in the background here,
but it's mostly a multiverse movie roping in characters
from many different universes, all different versions
or different variants of the X-Men.
Fantastic Four characters from the Fox Marvel movies
sort of meant to be a parody of those movies.
Really good example is the 20th Century Fox logo.
Wreckage is in the background
while Wolverine is trying to destroy Deadpool.
I think that scene is right
after they get dumped on the Void planet by the TVA.
So the whole joke here is that Kevin Feige,
quote unquote the TVA has pruned, Fox
because it was bought by Disney in
they're kind of getting rid of the brand, so to speak.
there are a couple of other things
that Ryan Reynolds posted recently.
There was a version of Kid Pool here,
so there might be a kid pool in the movie.
this could have just been him in real life, though,
having a random encounter with like some other kid
who's not in the movie who just happened to be dressed
like kid pool playing around,
he's posted videos like this all the time, though,
with like little kid versions of the X-Men
when the first Deadpool movie came out
just promoting that movie you have to imagine Deadpool
three being kind of like a version of this,
but with adult versions of the characters
in the original actors coming back, playing
versions of their characters,
now that Kelsey Grammer's Bees
just came back in that X-Men Post-Credits
scene during the Marvel movie, doesn't
this just feel so much more apropos?
a lot of you also wondering
what's going on with Hugh Jackman, Wolverine,
the other original X-Men actors
after the events of Deadpool three.
Well, the plan right now is that Deadpool
three is supposed to end
with a moment that immediately
sets up Avengers Secret Wars, which is why
I think that this void planet
is going to wind up being MCU Battle world
and it'll be sort of like a staging point
for the events of secret wars.
Marvel's changed a lot of their plans
for the upcoming Avengers movies,
particularly Avengers five,
because of what happened with Jonathan Majors.
There've been some recasting
that's going on Generally, though, the idea is that
by the time we get to Secret Wars in the movies,
it'll be more of like a multiverse.
Avengers situation with Doctor Strange
pulling together a bunch of different versions
of characters from other universes,
like the X-Men movies, the Fantastic Four movies,
and they'll face whoever winds up
being the main villain of that movie.
That's how they bring back, say, Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man, and give him scenes with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in a lot of the other characters
from those classic movies.
in Marvel's plan right now is to use that Secret Wars
movie is sort of like an Avengers endgame
for those classic X-Men, Fox Marvel, Fantastic
Four characters in a way that they never got.
Marvel will use the movie
to do a soft reboot on the MCU just in general,
so that going forward,
all the movies that take place in the main universe
will more closely resemble
the 616 universe of the comics,
like the Fantastic Four, the X-Men,
The Avengers will always have existed on the same plan,
and there won't be any kind of weird explanations
where the characters don't understand why.
They'll probably explain that like a couple characters,
like the Avengers
characters, some of the Multiverse characters
remember the previous version of the universe
in that they know there was a reboot that happened,
but for the most part, all the characters going forward
will just treat whatever the new universe looks like,
as if it's always been this way.
the funny thing about them
giving those classic Fantastic Four X-Men characters
their own version of Avengers Endgame is that Fox
actually tried to do something like that briefly.
There was going to be a Fantastic
Four X-Men crossover movie.
There was going to be a little bit like what
Captain America Civil War wound up being
that idea wound up falling through when Bryan Singer
agreed to come back and do X-Men Days of Future Past
and Fox pivoted to Days of Future Past
and just the future of the X-Men solo movies
because they thought that they would earn more money
doing that than doing a big crossover
with the Fantastic Four characters. Like, No, no, no.
We need to focus on the main X-Men movies.
you can let me know in the comments
if you think they made the wrong call.
Like even though X-Men Days of Future Past
was really solid, X-Men Apocalypse
not so much in X-Men Dark, Phenix also not so much.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Like I said, they're filming Daredevil Born again
right now.
We'll probably get some more footage from that soon.
So of course, I'll do more videos.
As we get more of that, we'll get that for Deadpool
3 trailer in the next couple of weeks.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
click here for all that new daredevil born again
footage and click here to learn what's going on
with Spider-Man four,
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield coming back
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!